[Music]
my name is Michael Mikey Cole I am the
chief ice-cream engineer and the founder
of Mikey Lake City the role of the ice
cream shop in the community is we are
the community little kids come in there
and we tell them you do good on your
report card the scoops on us the next
time because there was always a time
when we needed a little push just like
any other kid a neighborhood I wanted
more for myself than what was being
given to me I say so here I was selling
marijuana and ended up getting caught up
in the judicial system unfortunately and
then when I came out I learned that I
hurt others that was showing me love so
this is really about turning your life
around to show the community and the
kids growing up you don't have to
emulate a drug dealer you don't have to
always be an athlete to be known and do
something that should really love doing
find your passion
for me it's ice cream the way we make
our ice cream here Mikey likes it you
first start with the core ingredients
are salt sugar eggs heavy cream milk
that's all you need put all those in the
bucket in different measurements and you
keep starting to bring them together
multiply them then you want to make sure
that you level everything to be the same
taste because you're multiplying it and
then you add in the rest of your cream
your milk the edge of sugar then it goes
to the Machine a lot of people run ice
cream rather loose so it looks like a
thick and shake I like to learn to ice
cream a little tighter when it comes out
that machine's a little more dense what
that does is what you put in the freezer
it's a lot colder so the ice crystals
don't have a chance to form and creates
a better smoother texture flavor where
like Grandma candy bars without being
full
we have a cultures pop culture affects
the world in many ways if a musician
comes out and says something kids are
gonna listen to them before listen to
their own parents so I decided that we
need something that can gravitate to the
culture and so mesh ice cream with the
pop culture just seemed like a real
hand-in-hand fit
[Music]